you've tweeted
quote assembly theory explains why
nietzsche understood with limited
freedom rather than radical freedom
so we've applied assembly theory to
cellular in life and chemistry um what
does nietzsche have to do with uh
somebody's oh that gets me into free
will and everything
so let me say that again assembly theory
explains why nietzsche understood we had
limited freedom
rather than radical freedom limited
freedom freedom i suppose is referring
to the fact that there's constraints
or um
what is radical freedom what is freedom
so sasha was like believed in absolute
freedom um and that he could do whatever
he wanted in his imagination
and nietzsche understood that his
freedom was somewhat more limited
and it kind of takes me back to this
computer game that i played when i was
10. so i think it's called dragon's lair
okay do you know dragon's lair i think i
know dragons there yeah dragon slayer i
knew i was being conned right dragon
slayer when you play the game you're
lucky that you grew up in a basically
procedurally generated worlds was rpg a
little bit no it's like uh is it turn
based play was it it was a it was a
role-playing game but really good
graphics and won the first laserdiscs
and when you actually flicked the stick
you you took it's like it was like a
graphical adventure game with animation
yeah and when i played this game i
really you know you could get through
the game in 12 minutes if you knew what
you were doing for not making mistakes
just play the disc play this play disc
so it was just that timing and actually
was a complete fraud because all the
animation has been pre-recorded on the
disk yeah it's like the black mirror the
first interactive where they had all the
you know several million uh kind of
permutations of the movie that you could
select on netflix i've forgotten the
name of it so this was a exactly that in
the laserdisc so you basically go left
go right
fight the yoga
slay the dragon and when you flick the
joystick at the right time it just goes
to the next animation to play yeah it's
not really generating it yeah and i
played that game and i knew i was being
had
sorry oh okay i say see so to you
uh dragon lair is the first time you
realize that free will is an illusion
yeah
and
why why not does assembly theory give
you hints about free will whether it's
an illusion or not yeah so no so not
tightly if i do think i have some will
and i think i am an agent and i think i
can interact and i can play around with
my with a model i have of the world and
the cost functions right and i can hack
my own cost functions which means i have
a little bit of free will but
as much as i want to do stuff in the
universe i don't think i could suddenly
say i mean actually this is ridiculous
because now i say i could try and do it
right it's like i'm suddenly give up
everything and become a rapper tomorrow
right
maybe i i could try that but i don't
have sufficient um agency to make that
necessarily happen i'm on a trajectory
so when in dragon's lair i know that i
have some trajectories that i can play
with
where where sartre realized he thought
that he had no assembly no memory he
could just leap across and do everything
and nietzsche said okay i realize i
don't have full freedom but i have some
freedom
and i and the assembly theory basically
says that says
if you have these constraints in your
past they limit what you were able to do
in the future but you can use them to do
amazing things
let's say i'm a poppy plant and i'm
creating some opiates
opiates are really interesting molecules
i mean they're obviously great for
medicine great product cause great
problems in society but let's let's
imagine we fast forward a billion years
what will opiate the opioids look like
in a billion years well we can guess
because we can see how those proteins
will evolve and we can see how the
secondary metabolites will change
and but they can't go radical they can't
they can't suddenly become i don't know
like an um a molecule that you find in
an oled in a display
they will have some they will be limited
by their the causal chain that produced
them
and that's what i'm getting at saying
you're
we're predictive we are
unpredictably predictable or predictably
unpredictable predictably unpredictable
within a constraint on the trajectory
we're on yeah so the predictably part is
the is the constraints of the trajectory
and the unpredictable part
is the part that you still haven't
really clarified the origin of uh of the
little bit of freedom yeah so you're
you're just arguing you're you're
basically saying that
radical freedom
is impossible you're you're really
operating in a world of constraints that
are constrained by the memory of the
trajectory of the chemistry that led to
who you are okay but
uh you know even just a tiny bit of
freedom
even if everything if everywhere
you are
in cages
if you can move around in that cage a
little bit you're free i agree and so
the question is
in assembly theory
if we're thinking about free will
where does the little bit of freedom
come from what is the i
that can decide to be a rapper what why
what is that that's a cute little trick
we've convinced each other of so we can
do fun tricks at parties or is there
something fundamental that allows us to
feel free to be free
i think that that's the question that i
want to answer i know you want to answer
it and i think it's so profound i'd
let me have a go at it i would say that
i don't take the stance of sam harris
because i think sam harris when he said
the way he says it is almost it's really
interesting i'd love to talk to him
about it sam harris almost thinks
himself out of existence right because
because
do you know what i mean yeah well i mean
he has different views on consciousness
versus free will i think he saves
himself with consciousness he thinks
himself out of existence with free will
yeah yeah exactly so that means there's
no point right
so he's a leaf floating on a river yeah
um i i think that
he
he he's i don't know i'd love to ask him
whether he really believes that and then
we could play some games oh yeah no no i
then would say i'll get him to play a
game of cards with me and i'll work out
the conditions on which he says no
and then i'll get him in the conditions
he says yes and then i'll trap him in
his logical inconsistency with that
argument
because at some point at some point when
he loses enough money or the prospect of
losing enough money
um
there's a way of basically mapping out a
series of
so what what what will is about let's
not call it free will that what's
willa's about is to have a series of
decisions equally weighted in front of
you
and those decisions aren't necessarily
energy minimization those decisions
are a function of the model you've made
in your mind you're in your simulation
and the way you've interacted in reality
and also
other interactions you're having with
other individuals and happenstance
and
i think that you have there's a little
bit of delay in time so i think what
what you're able to do is say well i'm
going to do the counter factual i've
done all of them
and i'm going to i'm going to go this
way
and you probably don't know why i think
free will is actually very complex
interaction between your conscious
your unconscious and your conscious
brain and i think the reason why we're
arguing about it so it's so interesting
in the and we just some people
um outsource their free will to that
unconscious brain
and some people try and
overthink the free will in the conscious
brain
i would say that sam harris has realized
his conscious brain doesn't have free
will but his unconscious brain does
that's my guess right and that he can't
have access to the unconscious yeah and
that's kind of annoying and but so he's
just he's going to through meditation
come to acceptance with that fact yeah
just which is maybe okay i maybe but i
do think that i have
the ability to make decisions and i like
my decisions in fact i mean this is an
argument i have with with uh some people
that um some days i feel i have no free
will and it's just an illusion and this
is one and it makes me more radical if
you like you know as a
i get to explore more of the state space
and i'm like i'm gonna try and affect
the world now i'm really gonna ask the
question that maybe i dare not ask or
dare not or do the thing i dare not do
and that allows me to kind of explore
more it's funny that um
if you truly accept that there's no free
will
that is a kind of radical freedom
it's funny
but you're
because
the little bit of the illusion in under
that framework that you have that you
can make choices
if choice is just an illusion of
psychology
you can do whatever the hell you want
that's the but we don't do we and i
think but because you don't truly accept
that
you you think that there's
like you think there's a choice which is
why
you don't uh just do whatever the hell
you want like you feel like there's some
responsibility for making the wrong
choice which is why you don't do it but
if you truly accept that the choice has
already been made
then you can go
i don't know what is the most radical
thing
um
i mean but
yeah i don't i wonder what what am i
preventing myself from doing that i
would really want to do um
probably like humor stuff like
i would
i would love to if i could like
save a game
do the thing and then reload it later
like do undo it probably be humor just
um just to do something like super
hilarious
[Laughter]
that's super embarrassing and then just
go i mean it's basically just fun i
would add more fun to the world i mean i
sometimes do that because i you know um
i sometimes um
i try and i try and mess up my reality
in unusual ways by just doing things
because i'm bored but not bored i'm not
expressing this very well i think that
this is a really interesting problem
that perhaps the hard sciences don't
really understand that they are
responsible for because the question
about how life emerged and how
intelligence emerges and consciousness
and free will they're all ultimately
boiling down to some of the same
mechanics i think
my feeling is that they are
the same problem again and again and
again
the transition from a you know a a
boring world or a world in which there
is no selection so i wonder if free will
has something to do with selection and
models and and also the models you're
generating the brain and also your the
amount of memory and working memory have
available any one time to generate
counter factuals well that's fascinating
so like the decision making process is a
kind of selection yeah that could be
just absolutely yet another
yet another manifestation of the
selection mechanism that's uh pervasive
throughout the universe okay that's
fascinating to think about
[Laughter]
yeah there's not some kind of
fundamental its own thing or something
like that
that is just yet another example of
selection yeah
and in the universe that's intrinsically
open you want to do that because you
generate novelty
you